retour en france avec les conséquences
inattendues de la crise notamment dans
l'immobilier un chiffre d'abord donné
hier à l'occasion d'une réunion de la
fédération des promoteurs constructeurs
le nombre de mises en chantier de
logements neufs est en train de chuter
de 435 milles en 2007 ces mises en
chantier sont passées à 375000 prévu
cette année et les professionnels
tablent sur une nouvelle baisse à 330
milles pour l'année prochaine
dans ce contexte une pratique très
ancienne et remise au goût du jour
il s'agit du viager c'est un micro
marché mais il a le vent en poupe car il
permet notamment aux personnes âgées de
compenser une retraite souvent maigre
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé sophie mével et frédéric capron
aujourd'hui dany lance levée a rendez
vous avec un agent immobilier 78 mètres
carrés en région parisienne avec vue sur
les espaces verts
elle aimerait bien vendre pourtant pas
question pour elle de quitter son
appartement
cette femme a trouvé la parade elle veut
vendre en viager est à seulement 60 ans
l'évocation de sa propre mort se fait
sans tabou même si ce n'est pas tout à
fait le cas pour son entourage
c'est quand même de faire son testament
là la pression ça va vous faire des cds
plus vite
bon ben ça peu la même chose à la
réaction est un peu la même les gens ont
peur oui mes droits des comptes les gens
quand ils vont acheter mon affaire
engage ils vont bien devoir regarder ma
santé vont me demander ma température
gym en tête jusqu'à là quand même
eh ben ça peut ça quoi c'est vrai donc
ça fait peur à certaines personnes
depuis des années le viager n'avait plus
la cote il a souffert d'une anecdote
célèbre et cocasse jeanne calment avait
vendu son appartement en viager à 90 ans
un notaire
elle mourut 32 ans plus tard bien après
l'acquéreur mais aujourd'hui avec
l'allongement de la vie et la faiblesse
des retraites
le viager devient un produit de crise on
vend son bien de son vivant pour
bénéficier d'un capital et d'une rente
le plus souvent les vendeurs n'ont pas
d'héritier direct mais d'avoir des
enfants n'est pas un frein cela vous à
l'autorisation des enfants d'où vient
qu'il vous appartient
faites ce que vous voulez c'est dans
l'inconscient des gens ça fait de devoir
laisser quelque chose derrière soi pour
estimer les bien ce petit fascicule
bourré de statistiques
il tient compte de l'âge du vendeur et
de son espérance de vie tu vends que
c'est un homme une femme qu'il vit seul
ou en couple
cet homme vient d'acheter un viager au
coeur de paris nous emmène le visiter
bonjour 13 mètres carrés pour lesquelles
il a payé une première somme de 5000
euros à la signature et verse 380,0 de
rente chaque c'est le quatrième viager
qu'il acquiert pour lui il s'agit de
placement sur le long terme si je
récupère rapidement c'est c'est un plus
tout simplement
mais en en achetant plusieurs justement
je répartis les risques chez minimise
des chances d'avoir une jeanne calment
la vente viagère va également soulager
cet homme de 72 ans aux revenus modestes
des charges de copropriété ainsi que des
travaux de ravalement comme si vous
étiez locataires mais au lieu de me
l'envoyer jouer c'est juste après la
signature l'homme qui vit ici depuis 35
ans a eu un petit coup de mou c'était
comme s'il n'était plus chez lui
vous souhaitez une seconde et puis je me
suis dit bon c'est bien tu as passé une
carrière qui le voyait plat et le viager
aujourd'hui ils le voient avant tout
comme un petit coup de pouce pour
améliorer son quotidien